Acclamations
-LULA
LULA
-Lula est une barrière
contre la dictature.
-Il se pose comme quelqu'un
qui garantit
la stabilité démocratique
et la stabilité républicaine
dans un moment
de menace d'extrême droite.
Musique enlevée
...
En portugais
-Lula n'est pas un idéologue.
Lula est un homme du peuple
qui a décidé
de le sortir de la famine.
-Son projet politique est basé
sur sa vie.
...
-Le meilleur leader
du peuple brésilien.
-Destiné à devenir
un leader mondial.
...
-C'est le Pelé de la politique.
-Un symbole.
Un symbole de progrès,
de dialogue, de paix.
...
-Un phénix.
C'est un phénix.
-C'est la seconde chance
pour le Brésil
de se réconcilier
avec lui-même.
...
-Le 30 octobre 2022,
Luiz Inacio Lula da Silva était élu
pour la troisième fois
président du Brésil.
Une victoire historique
pour celui déjà élu il y a 20 ans.
Une revanche éclatante pour un homme
qui a survécu à un cancer,
a perdu la plupart de ses proches
et a été victime
d'un procès politique
qui lui a valu 580 jours de prison
avant d'être totalement blanchi
par la justice.
...
Un destin incroyable
pour quelqu'un dont la vie épouse
l'histoire de son pays
depuis sa naissance, en 1945,
dans le plus grand dénuement.
-La maison où vivait Lula était
une maison typique du Nordeste,
une maison avec un toit
et un sol en terre battue,
où les gens mangent et dorment
au même endroit,
une maison
où il n'y a pas de sanitaires,
où on ne peut rien planter,
car il n'y a pas d'eau
pour cultiver quoi que ce soit.
Il vient d'une sous-classe,
la classe de la famine.
Il appartient
à la classe qui meurt de faim,
ceux qui ne peuvent pas,
même s'ils le veulent,
devenir agriculteurs.
C'est encore en dessous.
-Une enfance...
tragiquement brésilienne,
dans le sens où il n'a pas
de figure du père.
C'est une mère qui élève
plusieurs frères et soeurs.
Certains de ses frères et soeurs
n'ont pas survécu,
parce que les maladies
prédominaient.
Pour les bébés,
c'était dur de s'alimenter.
Les conditions d'hygiène
étaient limitées.
Il est né dans un monde
où on n'était pas certain
de vivre jusqu'à 12 ans.
-Lula perd en effet
deux de ses frères et soeurs.
Mourant de faim, la famille migre
en 1952 vers Sao Paulo.
Cet exode rural
touche alors
des millions de Brésiliens.
-Il vient avec sa mère.
Ils sont huit enfants.
Lula est le septième.
Il arrive très jeune.
Il a 7 ans
et il doit déjà travailler.
Il a été cireur de chaussures,
puis petites mains dans un pressing.
Il raconte toujours
qu'il était tellement petit
que quand il livrait les vestes,
il devait lever les bras
car il était plus petit
qu'une veste d'adulte.
-Il raconte
qu'il ne mange jamais de fruits,
qu'il a mangé sa première pomme
à l'âge de 7 ans,
qu'il mâchait des chewing-gums
déjà mâchés
par un autre enfant.
Il a ces souvenirs
d'une enfance pauvre
dont il parle sans ressentiment.
Il en parle comme
d'une expérience de vie très forte,
et c'est un moyen pour lui
de se connecter
avec les personnes
qui vivent encore ça au Brésil.
-A 14 ans,
Lula entre à l'usine Volkswagen
où il devient tourneur-fraiseur.
Il va être touché par la dureté
des conditions de travail.
Il perd un doigt,
emporté par une machine.
-Chez Volkswagen a été organisé
par l'entreprise
un système de répression
contre l'engagement politique
des travailleurs.
Le dirigeant,
le responsable de cette répression,
était un commandant
d'un camp de concentration
en Allemagne.
Il a été recruté
pour venir au Brésil
faire ce travail de répression.
Tumulte
...
-En 1964,
la répression se durcit un peu plus.
L'armée fait un coup d'Etat.
Les chars sont dans la rue
et la dictature militaire s'installe
pour 21 ans.
Coups de feu
...
Cris de panique
Lula est déjà syndiqué,
mais sa priorité n'est pas
de combattre la dictature.
Il veut avant tout fonder
une famille.
Sa jeune épouse, Maria,
meurt en couches,
ainsi que son bébé,
par manque de soins.
Pour surmonter son chagrin,
Lula s'investit dans le puissant
syndicat de la métallurgie,
dont il devient
l'un des principaux négociateurs.
Musique triste
...
-L'histoire de Lula,
c'est l'histoire des Brésiliens
qui se réorganisent
en fonction
de l'industrialisation du pays,
dans les années 60-70,
et c'est cette industrialisation
qui crée une nouvelle façon
de faire de la politique,
au niveau des syndicats,
des mouvements sociaux
qui se sont forgés
pendant la dictature,
qui créent les conditions
pour que Lula devienne
un acteur compétitif.
-La popularité de Lula
commence à se dessiner
quand il devient
président du syndicat, en 1975.
Il redéfinit la stratégie
qui est d'être présent
aux portes des usines.
La force de Lula a beaucoup à voir
avec le contact
du quotidien.
Ce contact n'est pas seulement
une présence physique.
C'est un contact humain
très puissant.
-C'est une personnalité
très attentive aux autres,
très affable.
Il arrive à intéresser les gens
car il ne donne pas des cours,
il dialogue, il discute.
C'est un homme qui a une vocation
pour la vie publique
et qui a cette capacité
de communiquer, d'écouter.
D'ailleurs, c'est le propre
du leader syndical :
l'entente et la négociation.
Tumulte
-Mais malgré
ses qualités de médiateur,
Lula n'obtient pas toujours
gain de cause,
loin de là.
A cette époque, la confrontation
avec le régime
est très dure.
Il conduit des grèves pour améliorer
les conditions de travail,
augmenter les salaires
ou pour le droit de grève.
La réponse est violente.
...
-Lula a été arrêté plusieurs fois.
Lui et ses compagnons
ont été inculpés
par la loi de sécurité nationale,
qui est la loi la plus répressive,
instaurée par la dictature.
Lula a subi un procès
du tribunal militaire.
Ce procès a duré des années,
et à la fin, il a été innocenté,
ce qui montre bien
que c'était une tentative de miner,
de torpiller son leadership.
Cela démontre aussi
qu'il était déjà
un leader important.
Acclamations
...
-Un leader important qui déplace
des dizaines de milliers
de personnes lors de ses meetings.
...
-Protégé par cette popularité,
Lula n'a jamais été torturé
ni assassiné.
Ce qui n'est pas le cas
d'autres responsables politiques,
culturels ou syndicaux,
pendant ces années.
Musique sombre
...
-La prise de risque de Lula commence
dès le début de sa carrière.
Sociologiquement parlant,
c'est une prise de risque.
Un homme du Nordeste
qui prend un syndicat,
qui commence
à faire de la politique
avec ce syndicat,
jusqu'à aujourd'hui,
c'est vu comme inacceptable
par les élites.
-Non seulement Lula tient tête
à l'élite brésilienne
et à la dictature,
mais il réalise aussi son voeu
le plus cher :
fonder une famille
avec sa nouvelle épouse, Marisa.
Ils auront quatre enfants,
et c'est aussi un couple politique.
Marisa est une militante,
et sera de tous les combats.
Lula acquiert alors
une stature internationale.
-Lula est un syndicaliste,
dans les années 80,
qui voyage le monde,
qui rencontre les grands leaders
de la social-démocratie européenne,
qui va rencontrer
les leaders syndicaux au Japon,
les leaders syndicaux au Michigan,
dans l'industrie automobile.
La trajectoire de Lula se confond
avec l'insertion internationale
du Brésil,
du point de vue industriel.
-En 1980, Lula fonde le PT,
le Parti des travailleurs,
une manière de donner
un débouché politique
à des revendications
qui dépassent le cadre syndical.
Il faut dire que le pays
est toujours aussi fermé,
la répression toujours aussi dure,
les droits politiques
toujours aussi restreints.
-En 1984, il y a eu les plus grandes
manifestations politiques
de l'histoire du Brésil.
A partir de là,
la dictature militaire
a commencé sa chute.
Il y a eu un avant et un après.
Lula a été l'un des leaders
de ce mouvement
pour des élections directes,
et il est devenu
un leader national.
C'était une lutte syndicale,
au début,
puis elle s'est transformée
en lutte politique.
-En tant que femme de la favela,
en tant que femme noire et pauvre,
je voyais un travailleur
qui était en train
de créer quelque chose
qui me donnait,
pas seulement à moi,
mais à toutes les personnes
comme moi
l'opportunité d'avoir une place
et d'avoir une voix.
-Lula est tout d'abord candidat
pour être gouverneur
de l'Etat de Sao Paulo en 1982,
mais il perd largement.
-Il croyait qu'il allait gagner,
et il a été déçu,
car il a eu seulement
12 % des votes.
La légende raconte
qu'il a été avec Fidel Castro,
et que Fidel Castro lui a dit :
"C'est la première fois
"qu'un candidat de gauche
a autant de voix.
"Continue à lutter."
-C'est quand même drôle
que Fidel Castro donne
des leçons de démocratie à Lula.
-Ce n'est pas exactement
une leçon de démocratie,
c'est une leçon de persévérance.
-Persévérant,
Lula l'est, en effet.
Il est élu député fédéral en 1987.
Il se présente en 1989
à la première élection
présidentielle organisée
après le retour de la démocratie
dans le pays.
Il parcourt alors le Brésil
de long en large
avec ce qu'il appelle
"ses caravanes".
Acclamations
...
-Tous les politiciens font
des meetings, des discours.
Durant les caravanes,
Lula allait écouter les gens.
Il demandait :
"Comment va votre vie ?
"Quels sont vos problèmes ?
"Qu'y a-t-il de bon et de mauvais ?
"De quoi et comment vivez-vous ?"
D'ailleurs, il a
une expression drôle à propos de ça.
Il dit : "Que possède l'homme ?
"Une bouche et deux oreilles,
"pour écouter
plus que pour parler."
-Cette première candidature
à l'élection présidentielle
sera un échec honorable.
Lula ne se décourage pas
et se représente encore en 1993,
et encore en 1997.
-Mais il perd à nouveau
car son programme est encore perçu
comme trop radical.
-Si j'étais lui, j'aurais abandonné,
mais il n'a jamais abandonné.
Je me souviens que
quand nous perdions une élection,
quand la situation
était mauvaise,
parfois, nous, son équipe,
on se décourageait,
et il était le premier
à nous remotiver,
même quand il perdait l'élection.
C'était lui
qui aurait dû être triste,
mais il nous donnait du courage.
En voyant sa détermination,
on réagissait aussi.
*Musique festive
*...
-Le but recherché
depuis tant d'années
est enfin atteint en 2002.
Lula est élu
dans la liesse à la présidence
du plus grand pays
d'Amérique latine.
*...
-J'étais comme une folle.
C'était quelque chose
d'inimaginable,
une chose extraordinaire.
Je me suis agenouillée,
j'ai posé mon visage contre le sol
et j'ai remercié Dieu,
car c'était une chose incroyable.
*Fanfare
*...
-On craint un nouveau coup d'Etat,
mais le prédécesseur de Lula,
Fernando Henrique Cardoso,
va peser de tout son poids
pour assurer
une transition démocratique,
et lui passe l'écharpe de président
autour du cou.
-Pour une partie de l'élite,
le passage entre un monsieur,
un gentleman
très bien vu, mondialement,
comme Fernando Henrique Cardoso
et un monsieur comme Lula,
qui venait
des profondeurs du Nordeste,
a été vu comme un choc
et comme une rupture
dans les traditions hiérarchiques
et aristocratiques du Brésil.
Donc, Lula, je pense
qu'il incarne dans la perfection
les transformations sociales
du Brésil.
-Le Brésil est un pays riche
et développé,
mais très inégalitaire.
Quand Lula arrive au pouvoir,
30 millions de Brésiliens
ne mangent pas à leur faim,
comme dans un pays
du tiers-monde.
Les premières mesures
du président seront donc
les programmes d'alimentation
Fome Zero, "faim zéro",
et Bolsa Familia,
"bourse familiale",
pour que la faim cesse
d'être le problème numéro 1 du pays.
-Son idée centrale,
c'est de garantir trois assiettes
de nourriture par jour
à chaque Brésilien.
Il disait déjà ça
à l'époque du syndicat,
et il l'a encore dit hier
dans une interview à la télévision.
L'idée centrale,
c'est que le travailleur a besoin
de vivre mieux, juste ça.
Il ne s'agit pas d'une idéologie
de gauche, de droite ou du centre,
c'est la trajectoire d'une vie.
-Un homme comme Lula,
tout ce qu'il a fait pour nous,
les pauvres, pour les femmes,
pour les Noirs,
pour les gens des favelas...
Il a changé nos vies,
la vie de millions de personnes,
qui,
à l'époque du gouvernement de Lula,
en ont fini
avec le problème de la faim.
Et Lula a aussi fait
le plus grand programme
de logements populaires.
-Ce qui manquait au Brésil, surtout,
c'était la justice sociale,
et le gouvernement de Lula
a commencé vraiment
à prendre des mesures
pour réduire la pauvreté,
réduire l'inégalité.
Dans le passé,
l'économie pouvait croître
ou diminuer, n'importe,
l'inégalité augmentait toujours.
La première fois
que l'inégalité a diminué au Brésil,
c'était dans les gouvernements
du PT, surtout de Lula.
-Il sait
ce dont les gens ont besoin,
et je crois qu'il l'a traduit
dans son gouvernement.
L'accès au crédit,
pouvoir acheter des choses,
pouvoir manger mieux
et avoir une voiture,
laver sa voiture
le week-end dans sa maison,
c'est une chose que les Brésiliens
aiment beaucoup.
Faire un petit barbecue,
pouvoir acheter sa petite maison,
avoir une qualité de vie
plus humaine et décente.
-Sous la présidence de Lula,
ce sont ainsi
40 millions de Brésiliens
qui vont accéder
à la petite classe moyenne,
appelés les "emergentes",
les "émergents".
Musique douce
...
-Un jour, pendant un voyage,
nous étions
en train de déjeuner
tous les deux
et il m'a demandé :
"T'as déjà pensé à devenir
président de la République ?"
J'ai été surpris.
J'ai répondu :
"Ah, non, pas du tout."
"Et pourquoi ?"
"Parce qu'il faut être fou,
"pour vouloir être
président du Brésil,"
"il n'y a que des problèmes
à récolter."
Il m'a dit : "Pas du tout,
c'est formidable."
"Qu'est-ce qu'il y a de bien,
là-dedans ?"
"Tu peux résoudre
tous les problèmes."
Musique intrigante
...
-Un autre problème,
déjà brûlant il y a 20 ans,
que Lula va aussi tenter
de résoudre,
c'est la déforestation
de l'Amazonie.
...
-Nous avons réussi,
dans le gouvernement de Lula,
dans lequel j'ai été ministre,
à faire un plan de prévention
et de contrôle
de la déforestation de l'Amazonie.
Ce plan a réduit
la déforestation de 83 %
pendant presque une décennie.
Il a évité de rejeter
dans l'atmosphère
5 milliards de tonnes de CO2.
Il a aussi été à l'origine,
entre 2003 et 2008,
la période où j'ai été
dans le gouvernement,
de la création de 80 %
des terres protégées
dans le monde.
Musique de tension
-Marina Silva démissionnera
du gouvernement.
Elle estimait
que Lula n'allait pas assez loin
en matière d'environnement,
notamment en autorisant
la construction
du barrage géant
de Belo Monte,
au nord du pays,
pour l'irrigation
et l'électrification
de la région.
Musique de tension
-Il y a toujours une tension,
au Brésil,
entre ce qu'on appelle
l'agrobusiness,
l'agriculture commerciale,
et, disons,
les soucis environnementaux
et tout ça.
Mais le gouvernement de Lula
a montré que c'est possible
de réconcilier
une partie du Brésil
qui était comme l'Inde,
et une qui était comme l'Australie,
en termes d'agriculture.
Elles chantent en portugais.
...
-En termes de culture aussi,
Lula a tenté de concilier
les deux faces du Brésil,
en nommant ministre un chanteur
célèbre dans le monde entier.
...
-Quand Lula m'a proposé
le ministère de la Culture,
il m'a dit : "Gil,
"je veux que vous alliez
au ministère de la Culture,
"et nous serons un gouvernement
du peuple brésilien.
"Nous représenterons
une nouveauté
"dans la vie politique brésilienne.
"Allez-y,
faites dans ce ministère
"ce que vous feriez
"sur scène."
Ils chantent
sur un air festif.
...
-Comme une métaphore
de la politique de Lula,
le Brésil blanc découvre
la musique métissée
tandis que les favelas découvrent
la musique classique.
Les mesures sociales
du nouveau président
ne l'empêchent pas
de soutenir l'économie,
à l'image
du succès emblématique
de l'avionneur national Embraer,
le 4e constructeur
aéronautique mondial.
-Dans la période de Lula,
le Brésil a eu une croissance
de 4,1 % en moyenne.
Et la dernière année,
une croissance de 7,5 %.
Plus de 20 millions
d'emplois formels
ont été créés.
La dette sur le PIB
a été réduite de 60
à 39 %.
Le Brésil,
qui était endetté
auprès du FMI
est devenu créditeur,
et il a aujourd'hui
une réserve technique
de 300 milliards de dollars.
-Lula n'est pas d'extrême gauche.
Il ne l'a jamais été.
C'est un négociateur,
depuis l'époque du syndicat,
et il a apporté ça en politique.
-La force de Lula vient
du charisme qu'il a
avec les travailleurs,
mais aussi
avec les groupes dominants
au Brésil.
Cette capacité à se mouvoir
entre deux univers
extrêmement rivaux, antagonistes,
et à construire des ponts
qui puissent les réunir,
du point de vue
de l'expérience électorale
et de gouvernement,
c'est une habileté très spéciale.
Musique dynamique
-Cette capacité
à lancer des passerelles,
on la constate aussi
dans un autre secteur
très sensible au Brésil :
l'éducation.
Lula multiplie par 2
le nombre de places d'université
et il veille
à ce qu'elles profitent aussi
à une population
qui en était jusque-là
totalement exclue.
Ils l'acclament.
-Dans le domaine de l'éducation,
le gouvernement Lula a instauré
une politique de quotas raciaux,
socio-raciaux,
où les fils des travailleurs
et des travailleuses noirs
ont enfin eu accès
à l'université.
-N'oublions pas que nous sommes
un pays
d'origine esclavagiste.
N'oublions pas
que les anciens esclaves
n'ont pas eu de place
dans l'économie,
ni de place sur les bancs
de l'université,
ni d'accès
à des services publics
de qualité.
-Le pays est un pays
avec une majorité
d'Afro-descendants.
C'est le deuxième pays
avec la plus grande population noire
après le Nigeria,
donc ce serait
le deuxième pays africain au monde.
Cette politique des universités
a ouvert un débat,
qui existe au Brésil depuis 20 ans,
un débat extraordinaire
sur la place des Afro-Brésiliens,
des Brésiliens noirs,
dans l'histoire
et le futur du Brésil.
Le public siffle et l'acclame.
...
-La place des personnes d'origine
africaine dans le monde,
Lula va aussi la poser
à l'Assemblée générale de l'ONU,
par l'intermédiaire
de son ministre de la Culture,
le chanteur Gilberto Gil.
...
-L'origine africaine
du secrétaire général Kofi Annan
est la raison
pour laquelle je l'ai invité
à jouer sur scène,
d'une façon très spontanée
et informelle,
d'un instrument qui est typique
de notre héritage africain :
un des tambours africains
qui sont présents dans la culture
populaire et musicale
du Brésil, des Amériques,
et de tant d'autres parties
du monde.
Il chante en portugais.
...
Ils jouent un air festif.
C'était la première année
du gouvernement Lula
et cet acte à l'ONU a été
très significatif,
pour son gouvernement,
mais aussi, très profondément,
pour lui, personnellement.
Musique de tension
...
-Lula ne se limite pas à l'ONU.
Il renforce le groupe
des pays émergents des BRICS,
qui regroupe Brésil, Inde,
Russie, Chine et Afrique du Sud,
pour concurrencer
les pays les plus riches du G7.
Propos en langue étrangère
Applaudissements
...
-Ce n'est pas que la politique
extérieure du Brésil,
d'une façon générale,
était mauvaise,
mais il y avait toujours
une certaine timidité.
Il y avait :
"On peut pas oser faire ça."
"On peut pas oser
être trop actifs."
Et la grande différence
que je voyais, avec Lula,
c'est que,
à cause de ce qu'il représentait,
c'est qu'on pouvait avoir
une politique extérieure
très active et très affirmative.
-Lula !
Propos en portugais
Lula !
Senhor Presidente !
Clics d'appareils photos
-Cela se ressent jusque
dans l'attitude personnelle de Lula,
qui ne semble pas plus impressionné
que ça de côtoyer les grands
de ce monde,
y compris à la Maison-Blanche.
-Je vous donne un exemple.
J'étais assis avec lui,
quand on allait dans notre
première visite officielle,
en tant que président, lui,
à la Maison-Blanche.
J'étais à la voiture,
dans la voiture avec lui,
et pour lui, c'était une chose
tout à fait normale.
Il n'était ni nerveux,
ni impressionné
parce qu'il allait voir...
Non, c'était normal.
C'était normal,
c'était comme s'il était
avant ici,
quand il devait avoir
une négociation
avec le président de Volkswagen
ou de Mercedes-Benz du Brésil,
c'était normal.
Le traducteur répète
en anglais.
-George Bush est un républicain,
un homme conservateur,
et Lula, en peu de temps,
est devenu ami avec George Bush.
Beaucoup de gens
ne comprenaient pas ça.
Il y a eu
une réunion au Mexique,
à l'intérieur du Mexique,
à Guadalajara.
Quand la réunion des chefs d'Etat
des Amériques est finie,
je vois qu'il reste juste
Lula et George Bush
qui discutent au fond du salon.
Plus tard,
j'ai demandé à Lula :
"En quelle langue vous parliez ?"
"En portugnol", il m'a répondu.
C'est le mélange informel
de portugais et d'espagnol.
Il m'a dit :
"Mais t'es un ignorant !
"Bush vient du Texas,
et au Texas,
"on parle espagnol,
"donc nous parlions
en portugnol."
"Et pourquoi vous riiez tant ?",
ai-je demandé.
"Ah, ça,
je ne peux pas te le dire,
"ce sont des secrets
de chefs d'Etat."
Musique intrigante
...
-Lula est effectivement
un chef d'Etat
apprécié de ses pairs.
Après avoir conquis George Bush,
il va séduire son successeur
lors d'un sommet du G20
resté dans toutes les mémoires.
-Lula a toujours été
très attentif
à avoir
un rôle international majeur,
à se rapprocher des puissances,
à montrer
qu'il représentait le Brésil
dans les cercles mondiaux.
Parce que là, pour le coup,
ça changeait la perspective
de l'élite brésilienne.
Parce que le jour où Obama,
il dit :
"This is the most popular
politician on Earth",
c'est un choc pour cette élite,
qui ne voulait pas
reconnaître cet homme au pouvoir.
Donc Lula, il a toujours su jouer
dans la perfection
avec ces différentes dimensions :
la dimension globale
et la dimension très locale,
l'intérieur du Brésil
et les grands cercles diplomatiques.
...
-C'est comme ça que Lula finit
son deuxième mandat
avec une popularité record
de 87 %,
une popularité à faire rêver
n'importe quel chef d'Etat.
Crépitements des appareils photos
...
-Mais après deux mandats,
la Constitution brésilienne
ne lui permet pas de se représenter.
Musique de fanfare festive
...
La foule les acclame.
-Il passe donc le flambeau
à sa protégée,
Dilma Rousseff,
élue présidente en 2010.
Une revanche
pour cette ancienne guérillera
durement torturée sous la dictature
et un succès pour Lula,
qui enracine ainsi un peu plus
la démocratie dans son pays.
La foule crie de joie.
Des sirènes retentissent.
Mais comme usé
par trop d'années de combat,
Lula tombe malade.
Il a un cancer
et tout le monde pense
qu'il va mourir.
Musique intense
Il s'en sort pourtant et s'adresse
bientôt aux Brésiliens
en pensant déjà à un retour
dans le jeu électoral.
Musique de tension
Acclamations
...
-En 2015,
la successeure de Lula
est réélue
pour un deuxième mandat.
Elle favorise le lancement
d'une opération anti-corruption
qui touche tous les partis :
Lava Jato,
"lavage express".
Le Congrès,
dont de nombreux membres
sont mis en cause,
ne lui pardonnera pas.
Elle est victime
d'un coup d'Etat institutionnel
et écartée du pouvoir.
Lula se porte alors à nouveau
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
et se retrouve très vite
en tête des sondages.
...
-La droite, écartée du pouvoir
depuis maintenant 14 ans,
va alors tenter de retourner
l'opération Lava Jato,
"lavage express",
contre Lula, en engageant
des poursuites judiciaires
contre lui pour corruption.
*-Lula Lula
-Le destin s'acharne
sur l'ancien président
quand sa femme, Marisa,
partenaire de tous les combats
depuis plus de 40 ans,
meurt subitement
d'un AVC en 2017.
Lula est dévasté,
mais les obsèques de Marisa
se transforment malgré lui
en meeting politique.
-LULA, GUERREIRO
DO POVO BRASILEIRO !
LULA, GUERREIRO
-La descente aux enfers
n'est pas finie.
Après de multiples rebondissements,
Lula est condamné en 2018
à 12 ans de prison
pour avoir prétendument accepté
un appartement en cadeau
quand il était président.
Les accusations tournent
en boucle à la télévision.
Les Brésiliens doutent
et Lula accuse le coup.
Musique sombre
-Tout ça a été organisé
comme un spectacle.
Il était absolument essentiel
que Lula soit en permanence présenté
comme un criminel.
Donc, les médias n'ont pas cessé
de le faire passer
pour un personnage
odieux et criminel.
-Il y a eu un coup monté
pour éviter
qu'il brigue
un nouveau mandat,
où il avait beaucoup de chance,
car il avait fini
ses deux gouvernements
sur une approbation très forte
et donc
avec un très grand potentiel
en tant que candidat.
La foule scande des slogans.
...
-Le sort de Lula devient
un enjeu national.
Le juge Moro,
qui l'a condamné,
est nommé
ministre de la Justice
en remerciement
des services rendus.
Le pays est coupé en deux.
Les détracteurs de Lula
se réjouissent de sa condamnation.
Ses partisans lui conseillent
d'aller se réfugier à l'étranger
pour échapper à la prison.
De nombreux pays lui proposent
alors l'asile politique.
-LULA, GUERREIRO
DO POVO BRASILEIRO !
LULA, GUERREIRO
-Jamais il n'a été tenté
par cette hypothèse,
à cause de son respect
pour le jeu démocratique.
Lula, il sait
que le rêve secret
de l'élite brésilienne
est qu'il sorte
du jeu démocratique
parce que le jour où il sort
du jeu démocratique,
même quand ce jeu,
il est totalement biaisé,
il a perdu toute légitimité,
même quand ce jeu,
il est devenu illégal.
Ce que l'élite politique veut,
c'est que Lula commette la faute,
soit à l'initiative
de la faute morale,
parce que ce jour-là,
Lula, il est out.
Pales d'hélicoptère
La foule crie.
...
-Lula est donc transféré
par hélicoptère, de nuit,
au siège de la police fédérale,
dans une véritable scène de film
qui réjouit ses opposants.
Feu d'artifice
La foule scande des slogans.
Sous les feux d'artifice
et les pétards,
il entre en prison
pour 12 années,
et tout le monde est persuadé
qu'il y finira sa vie.
...
-On savait qu'il y avait
un symbole politique
dans cette condamnation,
qu'elle transcendait
l'histoire individuelle de Lula
et atteignait
notre propre démocratie.
Qu'il aille en prison
a été stratégique
pour l'élection
de Bolsonaro en 2018.
La fanfare joue l'hymne brésilien.
Acclamations
...
-Lula en prison,
la voie est effectivement libre
pour le candidat d'extrême droite
Jair Bolsonaro,
un ancien militaire élu
président en 2018.
...
Bolsonaro va mener tambour battant
une politique à l'opposé
de celle de Lula.
La misère et la faim refont
leur apparition au Brésil.
La déforestation de l'Amazonie
connaît
une accélération sans précédent.
Le ministère de la Culture
est purement et simplement supprimé
et l'on ouvre
pour les enfants pauvres
des écoles civico-militaires.
Musique grave
...
-La généralisation
de l'éducation publique et gratuite
jusqu'à l'enseignement supérieur
au Brésil
avait été
une mesure très importante,
et ce n'est pas un hasard
que ce soit cela qui soit détruit.
Quand je dis "détruit",
c'est vraiment "détruit".
C'est des immeubles
et des musées publics en feu,
des structures universitaires
qui sont fermées ou abandonnées
et la perspective
d'un approfondissement
de cette destruction,
avec des coupes très importantes
dans les services publics
brésiliens.
Détonations
Brouhaha
-Le président Bolsonaro
va autoriser
les milices privées
et libéraliser
les ventes d'armes.
Les échauffourées
sur la voie publique se multiplient.
Sirène de police
Détonations
Pendant ce temps-là,
Lula, lui, croupit toujours
dans sa cellule.
Musique douce
...
-Nous pensions
qu'il allait perdre le nord,
qu'il allait tout perdre.
Il a été très triste.
Il a passé des moments
très angoissants en prison.
Beaucoup de gens pensaient
que ce serait la fin
de sa vie politique,
qu'il allait sortir
pour mettre un pyjama
et vieillir quelque part.
Musique légère
-Mais même en prison,
Lula reste populaire.
Ses partisans ne le lâchent pas.
Certains campent même
devant la prison
depuis son incarcération
pour lui soutenir le moral.
-Tous les jours,
ils criaient :
"Bonjour, président Lula.
"Bonne après-midi,
président Lula.
"Bonsoir, président Lula."
Cela, symboliquement, a été
très important
pour garantir
que Lula puisse continuer,
qu'il puisse sortir
de cette situation
et qu'il puisse continuer
à représenter le Brésil
en ce moment historique
que nous vivons.
-C'est étrange
de voir un homme
d'une dimension mondiale, globale,
être dans cet espace,
mais son esprit était toujours...
...libre, toujours libre.
Je pense qu'il a même...
Il hésite.
Il a même, disons, grandi
dans cette époque
à la prison.
Il a beaucoup lu,
il a beaucoup pensé.
Air funèbre à la trompette
-Deux événements vont servir
de détonateur pour Lula :
la mort qui frappe à nouveau,
cette fois-ci son frère adoré Vava,
aux obsèques duquel
il lui est interdit de se rendre.
Quelque chose d'impensable
dans un pays catholique
comme le Brésil.
Musique funeste
Et un mois plus tard,
la mort de son petit-fils de 7 ans.
Cette fois-ci, il est autorisé
à sortir de sa cellule
pour aller à ses obsèques.
Comme toujours avec Lula,
cet événement privé se transforme
en événement politique
où il va prendre une décision.
-Au moment de la crémation
de son petit-fils,
il lui promet
qu'il va prouver son innocence
et que la seule façon
de prouver son innocence,
c'est de rester en prison.
Le premier message qu'il m'a envoyé
de retour en prison, c'est :
"Je vais sortir d'ici,
je vais être candidat,
"et le Brésil va être heureux
à nouveau."
-Lula repart en prison,
mais dans sa tête,
il repart en campagne.
Il est persuadé qu'il sortira
rapidement de sa cellule.
Et effectivement, en 2019,
après 1 an et demi passé
derrière les barreaux,
la plus haute juridiction du Brésil,
le tribunal suprême fédéral,
annule toutes les poursuites
contre lui
en pointant la partialité
du juge Moro, qui l'a condamné.
Lula est lavé de tout soupçon
de fraude et libéré.
Musique glorieuse
...
-Il a réussi
à ce que la justice
comprenne le coup monté
dont il a été victime.
Il a récupéré ses droits,
il a récupéré
sa capacité de dialogue
avec la société brésilienne,
à nouveau,
il a récupéré son prestige
et il a récupéré
sa force politique.
-C'est une prise
de risque énorme,
du point de vue
de son intégrité physique !
Et il a réussi son pari.
-Lula s'est transformé
en mythe
naturellement.
Supporter 1 an et demi
de prison
sans avoir commis
aucun crime,
simplement
parce qu'il croyait possible
de prouver son innocence,
Lula, à partir
de cette résistance,
qui est une résistance politique,
commence également à représenter
une sorte
de résistance spirituelle.
Le combat de Lula devient
un combat spirituel
pour soutenir la vérité,
car il sait que la vérité est
le fondement de la démocratie.
Musique grave
...
-Vérité et démocratie :
deux mots bien malmenés,
cette année-là, au Brésil.
Quand le Covid s'abat
sur le monde en 2020,
on enterre les gens
nuit et jour,
sans cesse, dans tout le pays.
Le président Bolsonaro
ne prend aucune mesure
pour protéger sa population.
Il y aura 700 000 morts.
Des images qui vont choquer
tous les Brésiliens
et le monde entier.
...
Et quand un vaccin est
enfin mis au point,
Bolsonaro appelle les Brésiliens
à continuer à se réfugier
dans la prière.
Vocalises religieuses
Lula, lui, se fait piquer
devant les caméras
et appelle tout le monde
à faire de même.
Crépitements d'appareils photo
-Lula a été réélu en octobre
par un front républicain.
Ce front républicain,
il naît dans la mobilisation
pour les vaccins.
Parce que, oui, il y avait
tout le Brésil démocratique.
Si on pouvait le mobiliser
par une question,
c'était : êtes-vous
pour ou contre les vaccins ?
Là, la ligne,
elle était très claire.
Il n'y avait pas de personnes
qui étaient contre les vaccins
qui avaient une vision
d'un Etat démocratique,
de santé publique,
qui avaient une vision
de responsabilité sociale.
-En 2022,
Lula est donc candidat
à l'élection présidentielle
pour la 7e fois de sa vie.
Le Covid reste un sujet important
de la campagne. Une fois de plus,
son histoire personnelle se confond
avec celle de son pays.
Ce jour-là,
c'est sa 3e épouse, Janja,
qui prend d'abord
la parole sur scène.
...
-La santé, la faim,
l'éducation : les sujets
qui avaient conduit
à la 1re élection de Lula
il y a 20 ans sont donc
de nouveau d'actualité.
Et si le tribun
a perdu de sa voix,
il n'a rien perdu
de son talent
pour haranguer les foules.
Voix enrouée
La foule l'acclame.
...
Musique victorieuse
-Lula a donc été élu
président du Brésil
pour la 3e fois
le 30 octobre 2022.
...
Mais de justesse,
à peine 51 % des voix.
...
La ligne démocratique a triomphé,
mais il a gagné d'un cheveu.
...
Alors, que va-t-il faire
maintenant ?
Mais surtout,
que peut-il faire ?
La situation n'est pas du tout
la même qu'il y a 20 ans.
...
-J'ai de la peine pour lui.
Il a 75 ans.
Il n'est plus tout jeune
et il va hériter
d'une terre dévastée.
Il va devoir tout recommencer
depuis le début.
Il va devoir
reconstruire le Brésil.
-Lula va conquérir
plus de droits
pour les pauvres
et il va réussir
à sortir le Brésil de la faim.
Il l'a déjà fait par le passé.
Et je crois
qu'il parviendra aussi
à contrôler la progression
de la déforestation
de la forêt amazonienne.
-Le Brésil est l'une des plus
grandes économies du monde.
Il a déjà été à la 6e place
pendant la présidence de Lula.
Aujourd'hui,
il va se réinsérer
dans l'économie mondiale.
Le Brésil peut être un exemple
pour le monde
dans le combat
contre le changement climatique,
pour la préservation
de l'environnement
et pour les énergies
renouvelables et propres.
-Au-delà de ces mesures concrètes,
l'enjeu est
aujourd'hui plus large pour Lula.
Le pays est fracturé.
Jair Bolsonaro n'a reconnu
sa défaite que du bout des lèvres.
Ses idées d'extrême droite ont
essaimé dans tout le pays
et ses partisans réclament
un coup d'Etat.
-Je dirais que le grand défi
qu'il a devant lui,
plus que de battre Bolsonaro,
c'est de battre le "bolsonarisme".
-C'est pas seulement
la gauche contre la droite,
c'est vraiment une vision
de la démocratie
et de la civilisation,
que Lula incarne maintenant,
contre une vision...
anti-civilisation,
anti-progrès de l'humanité,
contraire à toutes les valeurs
des Lumières.
-Il va faire combien de mandats,
Lula ?
-Un seul.
-Ah ? Pourquoi ?
-Parce que...
Le retour de Lula,
et ça, c'est le plus grand risque
qu'on vit,
ne peut pas seulement être
une parenthèse républicaine
dans un grand avènement
du populisme
et de l'anti-politique
qui a commencé en 2016.
Il doit être
la fermeture
de cette parenthèse extrémiste,
qu'on a connue sous Bolsonaro
et un peu sous Temer avant,
et l'ouverture
vers quelque chose de nouveau.
Je pense que Lula,
il sait très bien
qu'il doit faire
cette transition
et ce n'est pas seulement
une transition.
C'est donner un destin au Brésil,
un destin politique,
un chemin pour les prochaines
générations.
-Le destin du Brésil
se retrouve donc
encore une fois
entre les mains de Lula.
Quoi qu'il fasse,
une chose est sûre,
lui,
Luiz Inacio Lula da Silva,
l'ancien tourneur-fraiseur,
né dans la plus grande misère
et devenu 3 fois président de l'un
des plus grands pays du monde,
aura eu un destin extraordinaire.
Un destin dont il fut
le premier artisan,
le destin d'un homme
qui restera dans l'histoire.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Musique glorieuse
...